know that we're gonna celebrate the 25th
anniversary of the Dave Ramsey show this
segment what we chose to do is to take a
second that ever so often through the
summer here and up into the month of
September and we'll crescendo in the
month of September talking about these
things and then we will cease to bother
you with them again but we wanted to
celebrate the 25th anniversary and it
didn't seem appropriate to do it just
one single day and taking the whole
three hours so instead we just taken a
segment every so often and stop and talk
about it we did a town hall broadcast
with Ken Coleman our Remzi personality
interviewing me on Sirius XM earlier in
the week and I think you can listen to
that still it's online or you can pick
it up and find it if you want to talking
about the old days and talking about 25
years of doing this and that was a lot
of fun a whole bunch of you I think
about a half-million have you watched it
live on Facebook if I remember right I
was think that was the number they gave
me there's a lot of folks anyway thank
you for that thanks for joining us to
hang out and do that stuff you know one
of the things we've learned and I talked
to radio people in the industry all the
time about this people that are starting
their first talk show or that they're
struggling to get their talk show off
the ground whether they talk about
sports or politics or something like I
talked about about life and you know
instruction and helping someone with a
category in their life or something like
that one of the things we found is that
radio is talk radio in particular is
uniquely qualified for what we do and
here's why here's what's weird about it
these callers that call in we number one
we never ever tell a caller what to say
and 99 percent of time we know very
little about what they're gonna say so
what happens is Kelly talks to them for
a few minutes tells them you know to
shut off the noise in the background and
talk directly
their phone because people wander around
their cell phone all around their head
and you can't have hear them and you
know put the window up on your car you
can't have your air blowing in while
you're driving down the interstate we're
all gonna hear it you know and she
teaches them how to basically make the
call where we can understand it and then
she gets into the call a little bit
learns about what they want to talk
about what we do not tell them what to
call about and we do not verify in some
detail due diligence the information so
could they be lying
sure but most people don't bother the
lie they just tell you the truth and
truth that's the the fact is the truth
is much more entertaining some of these
folks man the stuff people get into I
mean can you you know the calls we've
had it's amazing but here's what's cool
because of that we have had a time or
two we told someone had an abusive
violent husband and we tell them to
change their name and change the city
that they're calling from because we
don't want to activate this piece of
trash husband right and that kind of
stuff and so you know we'll do some
stuff like that but it's this is it just
is what it is you know it and here's the
thing when George calls or Henrietta
calls I don't know if I've had a
Henrietta but anyway if you know
whatever name write calls it's kind of
anonymous cuz we're not on TV I'm on TV
you can watch me on the app and that
kind of stuff but you don't get to see
the person calling you don't get to see
John or or I don't know Rebecca or
whoever it is it's calling you don't get
to see them so it's kind of on their
part anonymous you know they're kind of
behind the curtain so to speak and the
magic of that is that that gives them
the courage to tell the truth about
what's really going on and since it's so
it's kind of an anonymous thing they you
know and you know most of the time I
think they use the real names most the
time they tell me they're real city and
that kind of stuff and you know but it's
kind of anonymous and so if they're
being stupid or if they've done
something really weird or perverted or
something and they talked about it here
on the air it's kind of a safe place to
talk about it in a weird way because
there's 14 million people listening but
nobody knows who they are the chances of
one of your friends being you know
having their car radio on at the moment
you call in and actually recognizing
your voice and going I didn't know that
about Rebecca you know they don't that
doesn't come up
I mean you pretty much have an anonymous
counseling session for a few moments
here on the air and can tell the truth
about what's going on that anonymity
allows us to get real and get real fast
and I honestly want to started this I
did not recognize that I didn't know it
but I've just observed this in 25 years
and what that does is it gives us the
ability to give people hope because if
they get real we can dig out the root of
the weed in their life and show them how
to win and we all you all get to listen
and hear that happen so this is a
serious platform for hope and it's an
intimate medium isn't it because it's
one-dimensional you're just using the
audio you're just using your ears only
not your eyes you're not seeing body
language you're seeing my body language
if you're watching it but you can't hear
the call you can only hear the caller
and you can tell when they're lying
can't you they hesitate they stumble and
you can tell when I've asked the same
question three times and they're still
dancing and dancing and dancing and
you're like driving along in the car
going he's gonna kill you you better
answer the question you're laughing to
yourself aren't you you know that's
gonna because I'm gonna be polite a
couple times but after that I'm just
gonna get up in your business right and
because I'm here to help you it's what
we do and we've had some really touching
calls some stuff that just made us all
just cry and had to go to a break you
know like the first one I remember the
most was a lady in San Antonio San
Antonio's big military town of course
and her husband had been killed in
Afghanistan and action on Sunday morning
she called me on Monday
and so brave I mean her voice wasn't
cracking up but I got tears running down
my cheeks I'm sitting there trying to
answer her questions and I can't breathe
this woman I mean she's got two little
kids and this you know this young
soldier they got an A in an ambush and
and you know she's crying a little bit
but she wouldn't ride as hard as I was
it was ugly
you know but why she called me he that's
weird mm-hm
it's not weird she didn't really call me
she needed information and information
helped her process her grief that's all
it was
it wasn't like day you did something but
we gave her the information and of
course the military does a great job of
walking with these folks in these
situations with their chaplaincy program
and all the insurance and all the whole
process but we plugged her into a good
church we got her in with some of our
smart Wester pros we got her in with one
of our coaches we pay for everything and
take care of just love on or just wrap
our arms around her while she's going
through this but this is a it's an
intimate medium and that's why it's been
such a privilege to do this for 25 years
a Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
hey Dave John Maxwell here we've done a
lot of things together over these 25
years that you've had this incredible
ministry and you're known by millions of
people is kind of like the finance guy
how many people get their financial back
together but what I appreciate about you
Dave is this behind doing all this
expertise in finances I know why you do
it you really want to help people you
want to add value to people you really
want to make a difference in people's
lives to me that's the Dave Ramsey I
know that's the name Ramsey I love and I
think that's the Dave Ramsey that god
bless the man who wants to add value to
people the one and only John Maxwell
thank you my friend I appreciate that
very much we continue with our 25th
anniversary celebration we're talking
about the anonymity of calls and how
this platform is so powerful for helping
people have hope and hope is an amazing
thing I mean when you believe you can
win because someone shows you how you
can win then you go do the things it
takes to win pretty cool and you know
we're talking about some of the touching
calls that we've gotten I was telling
about the in the last segment the lady
from San Antonio calling and it's
talking about her husband having been
killed the day before in an ambush in
Afghanistan serving as a serving in the
military and you know how we were
privileged to try to give her some
information which you know it's grief is
weird when you are dealing with grief if
you have information it I don't know
somehow it may if you know what is going
on and what you're facing even if it's
bad you it gives you some strength to
face it not knowing about stuff is what
is will drive you bananas in a grief
situation and
I mean I remember another time that I
was just we told a lot of funny stories
over the last few months of people
calling and crazy stuff people did on
the air but I mean it has it's amazing
IIIi know the call I got I remember a
guy was in Atlanta and he called me and
he had just left the oncologist and was
just told by his doctor that he had two
months to live they had cancer all over
him it had been testifies Dan and he you
know stage whatever I mean it was bad
and he just left the oncologist just got
this information was in the car driving
home heard me on the radio called pull
over on the south interstate he was on
his way home to tell his wife she know
call me what are you calling me for I
can't even imagine and all he wanted was
he wanted to walk through the basics of
an estate plan to make sure he thought
he had all this stuff in place but he
wanted to have that clear in his head
because he knew that if his wife knew
she was okay and the will was in place
and the life insurance was in place and
the powers of attorney were in place and
the different elements of an estate plan
were in place he knew that if he had
that information that this horrible day
this news he's gonna go home and tell
his wife was gonna be somewhat more
bearable and so he pulls over the side
of the road and he and I go through the
checklist and of course I start with I
mean do you know the Lord you know where
you're going and we go right down the
list and you know talk about a will and
does he need to update it and what
status is the life insurance in and what
kind of financial position are they and
and so we kind of laid out a plan of how
she was going to be financially okay and
once he knew she was going to be
financially okay it helped him deal with
his terminal diagnosis Wow
and I mean he and I are just talk
through this like it's some kind of
business transaction or something but
this guy's sitting there on the side of
the road finding out he's dying and he
got at the end of the call and kind of
got choked up and that's when I lost it
you know I had to go to a commercial
break I couldn't get through I'm just
crying like a thirteen year old girl I
mean is bad but uh that's the kind of
stuff over the years of doing this show
that we've had the the privilege the
honour of being involved being
trustworthy enough to be involved in
someone's life at some of the worst or
some of the best times we've had people
doing the debt free stream screams that
says they finish their debts free scream
drops down on one knee and says will you
marry me and she says yes and we get all
that on film for him the engagements all
right here in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions if you were saying you had a
financial show who would have thought
something like that would happen or
these other calls would happen which
proves to you this is not a financial
show nobody would participate with those
key life things in this show if it was
just about money now this show shows
about your dreams shows about your fears
shows about your destiny and more than
it-- you're going to get there and how
you're gonna get there
and that's why this thing has worked for
25 years it had one program director
call me up in the radio business many
years ago and he said des we have to
take you off the air so why are you
taking me off there I don't want to lose
that city because I'm afraid we're gonna
get sued get sued yeah get sued on us
and you're gonna get sued over get
somebody out of debt you think you're
going to sued over that I mean really he
goes now your show is so boring
I'm afraid somebody's gonna be driving
and fall asleep listening to it and run
off the road and you have a car wreck
and I'm afraid I'm gonna get sued he was
dead serious that was his way of telling
me he was taking me off there I was
getting fired horribly he did he took me
off the air and I'm back on
in that city by the way and he's not in
the radio business anymore and we're
still here so I guess boring has worked
out for us and didn't work out for him
but that's why I can remember getting
fired
we've getting to get thrown off a bunch
of stations over the years for Dell
kinds of different reasons but that was
great absolutely fabulous back when we
only had a handful of stations there
were some idiot we had a governor that
was in Tennessee there was an idiot and
he couldn't balance the budget and
Tennessee has a constitutional command
or whatever you call it a constitutional
requirement of a balanced budget so if a
Tennessee governor says we balanced the
budget that's because they had to don't
have a choice and so but this guy
couldn't balance the budget he couldn't
figure it out he was spending money left
and right and then I had all these
things he wanted to do and so he didn't
have enough income coming in so he
decided that Tennessee needed a state
income tax well I went off on this bozo
and I started taking the state budget
apart on the air and going through line
by line and I found out they were
spending almost four hundred million
dollars on putting wildflowers in the
median in the interstate and crap like
this I mean I'm just ripping these
people to shreds and he's coming out
going trying to scare tactics if if you
don't pass the state income tax we're
not gonna have the money to send
kindergarteners to school and the
Highway Patrol is going to not be able
to protect you and everybody the anarchy
is going to break out and all this fear
mongering stuff so I got to tell you man
me and a couple of other local talk
radio hosts phil valentine was on at the
time Steve Gill was on the time in
Nashville and we went to town on this
guy and on this state legislature and we
had people circling the Capitol honking
horns you couldn't Drive in downtown
Nashville for the protests there was no
Tea Party in those days it was before
there was a tea party but we said we're
gonna do a Tennessee tax revolt send tea
bags to your Congress Tate senator your
state representative and to this day you
can smell tea in a lot of those offices
I mean truckloads of tea was delivered
and it was the biggest uprising I have
ever been a part of our every scene and
we the people got all up in their face
basically ran that guy out of town on a
rail and the any any of the legislators
that were for it didn't get elected the
next time through and last election
cycle we now have passed a
constitutional amendment for the state
state constitution in the state of
Tennessee that forbids a state income
tax that anger still lingers in this
state and we were right at the tip of
the spear on that that's the power of a
platform like this to activate people
pretty cool stuff it's been a while 25
years old this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]